ein ritual auf dass wir dieses jahr wohl
verzichten werden müssen ist das böllern
es wird wohl ein sehr stilles ein sehr
stilles silvester werden und wir
sprechen nur mit einem menschen einem
mann andreas voigt dessen existenz
dessen berufliche existenz auf
knallkörpern fuß heftig wie bei ihre
erste reaktion als sie am sonntag als er
am sonntag erfahren haben dass bildern
de facto verboten sein wird an silvester
ich wollte natürlich auch so geschafft
das ist ja ganz klar
wir haben schon einiges erlebt und auch
einiges durchgemacht in den letzten
tagen bilder vom pult stand schon einmal
zur debatte da haben wir alle geschützt
weil er muss davon ausgehen
wir bereiten das dich ja für ein jahr
lang vor so lange gehen wir in
vorleistungen mit allen kosten
und dann sieht man plötzlich seine
existenz sind gefahren dann war das
feuerwerksverbot vom tisch wir haben
alles was liegen geblieben ist
spontan wieder aufgeholt mit viel viel
arbeit mit viel engagement
ja und dann diese nachricht haben am
sonntag
da ist man natürlich völlig von den
socken und man kann auch die
entscheidung nicht wirklich
nachvollziehen
also zum gewissen teilen wo ich aus aber
wir denken wirklich dass es eine falsche
entscheidung die überstürzte
entscheidung und auch entsprechende
beratung mit fachkundigen beratern kann
doch nicht stattgefunden haben ja jetzt
meister dann gesagt sie haben die ganzen
raketen natürlich schon und alles andere
was man an silvester normalerweise dann
so bei sich weg zündet was ist jetzt da
ihr plan wollen sie das silvester
verschoben wird oder wird das einfach
alles weggeworfen kann man das aufheben
wie geht es jetzt weiter
das geht natürlich auf keinen fall ein
feuerwerk ist ja auch gefahren wo das
muss auch entsprechend gelagert werden
und da verschiebt sich das eine problem
in eine andere ist nämlich ja was
passiert jetzt mit die ganzen
feuerwerkskörper die bereits im handel
sind die müssen ja zurückgeführt werden
das heißt noch mal transport auf der
straße immer neue der einlagerung die
gegenstände müssen doch mal angefasst
werden
also ich würde dafür plädieren dass die
feuerwerks gewährsmann dort verbleiben
groß ist sind auf alle fälle und die
ideen er ist der beste in einer
bestimmten form nachzuholen das kann zum
beispiel eben auch wenn nationalfeiertag
sein oder eben ja alle einen beliebigen
anderen tag der uns wirklich grund zum
feiern gibt
ich halte das für eine sehr gute idee
vor allen dingen bei da nicht eine
komplette saison ausgefallen sondern ist
das war einfach nur später stattgefunden
also vielleicht wenn wir dann endlich in
deutschland impfen oder zum start der em
das soll nächstes jahr dann auch sein da
gibt es verschiedene termine aber dass
jetzt das böllern zumindest in diesem
jahr erst mal ausfällt denken sie dass
liegt wirklich an corona oder ist das
jetzt ein grund um silvester eben
umzugestalten die rufen
danach gab es ja auch schon den
vergangenen jahren genau diese
befürchtung bestehen natürlich bei uns
in der branche immer man muss nur
aufpassen dass man jetzt hier nicht zu
den für würden da als träger gerät und
man
naja verschwörungstheorien im prinzip
aufgreift das halte ich persönlich für
blödsinn
aber ich denke eher dass eine bestimmte
kompetenz einfach klären ist das vor
fünf jahren an einem beispiel mal
aufgefallen und hat einen grünen
politiker gefordert
das doch die bilder von der lautstärke
her in deutschland präsentiert werden
müssten die sind zu laut diese
reglementierung gibt es schon lange
schon lange von dieser forderung
man hätte sich einfach nur mal kündigen
müssen das was der gute mann der
politiker dort gemeint hat das sind die
illegalen bürger und genau das ist
nämlich auch das problem diese bilder
die auch eben auch den unmut in der
bevölkerung das ist das problem ist es
auch das was unsere tiere verschreckt
normale bürger die haben die lautstärke
ja dann lächelt er
dies trübe aber es ist durchaus als
ausreichend für uns silvesterfeuerwerk
allerdings was vom osteuropäischen markt
teilweise zu uns hier über schwach das
macht uns all die großen sorgen und eben
auch den teil der bevölkerung die sich
natürlich nicht so intensiv wie wir mit
feuerwerk auseinandersetzen den ist das
nicht klar für die ist es das feuerwerk
und nicht das illegale feuerwehren und
die kohl und die damit herumspielen
dank andreas folgt für diese
einschätzung aber rund um das feuerwerk
auf dass wir in diesem jahr zumindest
erstmal verzichten müssen
dankeschön mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bild schaut euch hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren